euh la question de l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne était
quand même assez complexe pour les
Européens oui alors elle est assez
complexe et c'est vrai que comme
ça vient d'être dit à l'instant par
Caroline de Camaret Selens qui là il a
ses urgences c'est-à-dire essayer de
résister à l'offensive que prépare la
Russie qui dit-il veut se venger
notamment à l'est se venger de son
humiliation en fait des mois passés d'où
effectivement ces demandes d'armement de
sanctions de sanctions cibles etc et
puis au-delà de l'urgence c'est pour ça
qu'il dit la question n'a été posée
est-ce que vous allez faire le voyage de
Bruxelles comme vous avez fait celui de
Washington il a dit oui je j'aimerais
bien en fait mais pour le moment voilà
c'est ça qui se prépare c'est cette
offensive moi il faut que je défende mon
pays il faut que les objets donnent des
armes etc et donc quand on sort un petit
peu de l'urgence mais tout ça il est
bien sûr après l'objectif c'est
l'adhésion effectivement à l'Union
européenne et de ce point de vue là en
fait disons qu'il a eu un un très fort
encouragement sur le thème l'Ukraine
fait partie complètement de la famille
européenne voilà c'est c'est un premier
raki de cette guerre il faut se souvenir
que comme la Dimière a fait ça c'est
pour que l'Ukraine revienne dans le
giron russe et bien pour le moment c'est
raté parce que l'Ukraine est allé
complètement ce que vous voulez
absolument éviter Vladimir Poutine dans
le giron européen et
otanien même si pour le coup
l'intégration à l'automne n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour concernant l'adhésion à
l'Union européenne en fait ce qui s'est
passé là aujourd'hui c'était un très
fort soutien symbolique un premier
calendrier en rappelant que l'Union
européenne avait accepté assez vite
finalement que l'Ukraine soit candidat à
l'Union européenne il y aura un premier
rapport de la Commission européenne à
l'automne et là vont commencer les
négociations la question qui reste en
suspense c'est à quel rythme si on fait
comme pour tous les pays précédemment
qui ont rejoint l'Union européenne ça va
prendre beaucoup de temps mais certains
disent oui mais il faut quand même faire
attention il y a des choses qui ne sont
pas encore au niveau côté ukrainien en
termes d'État droit d'indépendance des
pouvoirs de lutte contre la corruption
mais il faut donner la perspective qui
est que tôt ou tard l'Ukraine rejoindra
l'Union deviendra un membre de l'Union
européenne merci beaucoup pour Bruno
pour votre décryptage